Hillary Clinton says Biden's age is a
legitimate issue people have every right
to consider it is what she said during
an interview at the financial times
weekend Festival Clinton addressed Biden
stumble
at the G7 Summit saying every time that
happens your heart is in your mouth
because these things could be
consequential is that a concern it's a
concern for everyone while other
Democrats have dismissed age-related
concerns Clinton expresses her belief
that Biden can be re-elected stating I
obviously hope he stays very focused and
able to compete in the election because
I think he can be re-elected and that's
what we should all hope for then Joe
Biden peddles his worst lie in front of
U.S Marines during Japan trip which this
is this is just uncomfortable it's
awkward it doesn't make any sense to
make this kind of a blunder during his
trip in Japan President Joe Biden
falsely claimed my son was a major in
the U.S army we lost him in Iraq
referring to his son Bo's death however
Beau died of brain cancer in America
Biden has repeatedly made this false
statement to portray himself as a gold
star parent and score political point is
the president's erroneous remark
occurred during an informal visit with
troops at Marine Corps Air Station
awakuni the traveling press Corps was
kept at a distance in the White House
did not release an official transcript
potentially allowing the error to go
unnoticed by the public the fabrication
has been previously called out including
by the New York Times Biden's false
claim diminishes the sacrifices of those
who died in combat and is seen as
Shameless and disrespectful equating his
son's death from cancer with the deaths
of soldiers in Iraq and Afghanistan is
deeply problematic
do you have the clip yes go for it
was a major U.S army
thank you thank you thank you thank you
it's just that's the go ahead shameful
infuriating I'm a veteran you're a
veteran as well
and look what this speaks to is the fact
that this is somebody that's obviously a
mental decline if you watch Joe Biden if
you watch his action you see him
stumbling up these steps you see him
tripping over the teleprompter if you
see him telling these outright lies this
is somebody that needs to be sitting
down on in a rocking chair on a porch
right now playing with his grandkids
this is not somebody that needs to be
the leader of the Free World but here's
the thing he has given a pass on this
over and over and over again because
when he lies who's gonna point it out
conservative media the New York Post et
cetera et cetera um in mainstream media
is just going to pretend that this
doesn't happen uh they're just going to
you know just just sweep it under the
rug
um and I want to get back to one thing
about Hillary Clinton making the remark
about Biden's age and this is going to
be an unpopular opinion I love Hillary
Clinton I'm obsessed with her she is so
evil she is so unbelievably evil she is
my favorite super villain she's like
Thanos in The Avengers like this is why
I love Hillary Clinton so much because
she is just so fundamentally evil and
what you have to understand about is
super villain that is fundamentally evil
as Hillary Clinton is that there is not
a word that comes out of her mouth that
does not have a political motive behind
it she knew exactly what she was saying
right there she knew that these remarks
were gonna go go viral and there is a
point there is a reason behind her
talking about Biden's mental decline
um in his cognitive decline and all of
this other stuff does that mean that
she's trying to get in I don't put
anything past Hillary Clinton at this
point
um does this mean that they're trying to
get somebody to run against Biden who
knows but the blood is in the water
Hillary Clinton that villain that that
evil human being right there saying this
um there's some political motivations no
doubt that she has an agenda every time
she speaks can we play this clip rub
yeah it's like is she running or is she
still pissed at him that's what I was
thinking when I heard it
raise the audience they're whispering
really that low time that happens
your heart is in your mouth because
these things could be consequential is
that a concern
well I mean it's a concern for anyone
um and we've had presidents who've
Fallen before who are a lot younger
um and people didn't go into you know
heart palpitations
um but he his age is an issue and people
have every right to consider it
but you know he has this great saying
and and you know I think he's right you
know he you know don't judge him by
running as the almighty but against the
alternative and
I am you know of the camp that uh I
think
you know he's determined to run he has a
good record that three years ago people
would not have predicted would have
gotten done uh he doesn't get the credit
yet that he deserves what is happening
out in the country by the way you know
the people people call a lot of people
as the greatest poker players of all
time is there a better poker player than
her she's she's got a two out of 10 and
she'll look at you as if she's got
pocket aces there's not a better person
in the game than Hillary Clinton she may
be the greatest poker player of all time
look guys this this is what I this is
what I skilled about she is the skill
policy she is this is what I tell my
audience all the time I'm problematic
out there I say this all the time these
people think that you are stupid
these people think that you're dumb
these people think that you do not know
facts these people think that you will
believe everything that they tell you so
when Hillary Clinton sits on that stage
and she talks about Biden having a good
record the expectation is that the
people that are watching her are dumb
enough to believe everything that she
says she she by the way I wonder if it's
comedy I wonder if she thinks people are
dumb and I wonder if people actually buy
what she has to say so if you like this
clip and you want to watch another one
click right here and if you want to
watch the entire podcast click right
here
[Music]